how's everybody doing tonight III bought
a new shirt for this so I thought it was
cool my friend backstage was like you
look look at the guy who sold Elvis's
pills nice I'm a I'm a bad driver I've
gotten pulled over five times but I've
never gotten a ticket which is cool if
you're a hot chick or a famous person
but that means that every time a cops
pulled me over he's looked into the
window and gun you know he really
doesn't need this right now I'm not
gonna give him a ticket but I'm gonna
give him a soup in a winter coat so I
cut somebody off not proud of it that
person started tailgating me I'm like oh
no I'm gonna die I'm gonna die I'm gonna
die person goes in the left-hand Lane
Falls right next to my car I'm like I'm
gonna die I'm gonna die don't look over
I'm gonna die don't go over I'm gonna
die don't look over I look over and it's
a woman in her late 40s giving me the
double bird while she makes her 11 year
old daughter hold the wheel Hey I was so
upset because I've never been that close
with my mom you know I we can't agree on
a movie let alone perform a hate crime
together speaking of moms I did for
Hillary even though my goatee is
campaigning for Kid Rock all the Trump
supporters everybody oh oh he's got no
filter he says what he means he's got no
filter but what if he does have a filter
and this has just been the [ __ ] he
thinks is safe to say how scary
[Music]
he's a knowledge advisors he's allows
advisors he's like oh my skins are
rapists and Puerto Ricans can see in the
dark and they're like alright we'll go
with the first one I can't have people
thinking the president thinks Porto
Ricans are x-men so I'm a dumb liberal I
know a lot of dumb conservatives I'm a
dumb liberal I've met somebody and
they're and they were like I don't
believe I'm going I'd be like you're an
idiot
alright explain it to me and I'm like
well the the gases are released and co2
and it causes the the polar ice caps to
melt and increases the seas and then one
of the seas hits New York City and takes
out the Statue of Liberty and then
there's a snowstorm and wolves released
and the Wolves chased Jake Gyllenhaal
and the girl from shameless but that's
just the plot it's after tomorrow and I
yell feel the burn and I throw a
dreamcatcher and I run away
I'm a member like even though I'm
liberal I like country music but
sometimes country music I mean you could
tell sometimes
country music if you're just sing along
with stuff you're morally opposed to
right woke up this morning feeling fine
all right all to climb a mountain right
as long as those black sheets are
different water fountain what the hell
is that
I just rhymed me into being racist and
then every other country song is the
guys singing about what happened to him
at the present time that he wrote that
song woke up this morning put on my
shoes put on my pants which is hard cuz
my shoes are already on sat in a chair
cuz that's where you sit I drink water
I'll trigger through my mouth I breathe
through my nose cuz there's water in my
mouth
god bless the troops like god damn you
for bringing the troops into this
because you know how to property's a
metaphor you hickory-smoked piece of
[ __ ]
um I'm sober I'm a timer at a 12-step
group which is a really weird job that
means I have to cut people off if they
go over time you know so somebody's like
so there I wasn't the Jersey State
Turnpike selling my last toe for heroin
and and time come back next week we'll
find out what happened to fingers so I
used to have a cocaine problem I
couldn't afford it boom ruin my life
really was not good for my life
well cocaine early nineteen hundred's
late eighteen hundreds you could go to a
doctor and get cocaine prescribed you
how did that even work we're like hey
doctor had a bad case the heebie jeebies
from all these goosey flappers is that
way everybody talks like that back then
was everyone just on cocaine where it's
like one for you two for sheep and eight
ball for me and many more
[Applause]
you